- All right.
We are back and it's season four.
We are in New York city
and we are celebrating
Hispanic heritage month
with Lin-Manuel Miranda,
Ozuna and Angie Martinez.
(crowd cheers)
- So last season, Angie
and I played some games
out in Coney Island here in New York city.
And well things didn't go her way.
(crowd laughs)
Yeah.
- She was in, I grew up
in Coney island and I was trying to be,
I was trying to show her
a little hospitality.
- [Kelly] Yes, yeah.
- And let her have a moment.
And then she took it too far.
- You are so kind, you are so kind.
So it's time for a rematch
with a game in honor
of Hispanic heritage month
called "Angie's Second Shot."
(crowd laughs)
(upbeat jingle)
(Ozuna and Kelly clap)
- When I, when I pick on
you, it's love, it's love.
- It's crazy.
I don't know why I come here for this.
Why am I subjecting myself to this?
Ozuna, listen,
I just wanna make sure that
you're focused here because
- Let's go, let's go.
- All right.
- So wait, teams are me and Lin,
versus Angie and Ozuna.
(group laughs)
- I don't know what we're
playing but I got it.
- I got it.
Okay, Lord, are you there?
Do you mind hosting this game for us?
- [Lord] Hola, Kelly.
You see what I did there?
- I did, God, you are so clever.
- [Lord] Yeah, I'm
sorry, I'm busy right now
turning the oceans into coquitos.
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Amen, hallelujah.
- [Lord] So everybody get
ready to have a good time.
I will read a question
about something or someone Hispanic.
Could be from Hispanic pop culture,
could be from Hispanic cuisine.
You just have to wait and see.
Now, if you want to answer for your team,
you just hit your button
and you give it a shot.
You can buzz in early
but then you won't hear
the rest of the question
and the other team will
have a chance to steal.
Here's your first question.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Jennifer Lopez.
(everybody laughs)
- [Kelly] Wouldn't it be
amazing if it was correct.
- [Lord] All right, here you go.
- The odds were good.
- [Lord] What Colombian actress
starred for 11 seasons on
(buzzer beeps)
- Oh, oh, I know this one.
- He rang it first.
(crowd laughs)
- Sofia Vergara.
- [Lin and Kelly] Sofia Vergara.
(bell chimes)
- [Lord] It is Sofia Vergara.
(crowd claps)
That's a fun name to say that's right.
- [Kelly] Way to hit it fast.
- [Lord] So that's Lin-Manuel and Kelly.
You guys got one point, look at that.
- Hey.
- You have to get closer to it.
- [Lord] Better watch out
Angie, better watch out.
All right now here's your next question.
This Puerto Rican actress known
for West Side Story was the first actress
(buzzer beeps)
- Rita Moreno.
(bell chimes)
- It is Rita Moreno, look at that.
Uh oh, uh oh.
- Yeah, I, I shoulda got that too.
I just didn't.
Yeah, I don't know what I'm doing.
- [Lord] Here's your next question.
What was the title
of Disney's first Latin
American animated film?
(buzzer beeps)
- "Coco."
(loud buzz)
- Oh, is it?
- [Angie] Do you know it?
- First, the first one ever?
- I don't know.
- Can we go again if they don't know?
- [Lord] Well what goes
- [Angie] No, you can not, no, no.
- Well then maybe say something.
- They got it wrong.
- Spit something out.
- [Lord] Five more seconds.
- Somebody in the audience?
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't you do it, don't you do it.
(crowd laughs)
(loud buzz)
- [Kelly] No cheating.
- [Lord] The answer was Encanto.
- [Kelly] Encanto.
- Oh.
- [Kelly] I thought you would know that.
- The only reason I thought it wasn't is
because I was like well if it
was that then he would know.
- Coco, Coco is Pixar.
I looked at you and then you
didn't say it so I thought
"I don't wanna sound a dumb ass."
- Oh, Disney animation versus Pixar.
- Yeah.
- [Angie] I was gonna say that.
- I don't know if you noticed.
- That's really embarrassing
I did that then.
(Ozuna laughs)
- We should just win, we should just win.
- [Lin] Feel very embarrassing.
- That should be like a forfeit.
- Anne Hathaway beat me on a game
because she did "Since You've
Been Gone" and I didn't.
(audience laughs)
So it happens to the best of us.
- [Lord] The answer
once again was Encanto.
- Yes, I'm familiar with
the film, thank you.
- [Lord] That's right, Lin-Manuel.
(everybody laughs)
It's your chance to redeem
yourself, now Lin-Manuel.
Don't you worry.
- Okay.
- [Lord] I got your back, here we go.
In 2019, the library of Congress
preserved the Richie
Valens version of this song
(buzzer beeps)
- [Angie and Lin] La Bamba!
- I said it first.
- I hit it first.
- We said it, we said it, we said it!
- La Bamba, La Bamba, La Bamba.
- He said it!
(group sings)
- [Lord] That is correct.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
(everybody laughs)
- Just 'cause you sing it doesn't mean
- This was red, this was red.
We hit it first.
- [Audience Member]
Yeah, you had, you had.
- I said it first.
Does it matter?
- No, no.
- Wow.
- Hey, what's up?
- Hi.
- Hey.
(audience claps)
- Remember that time, that it's still
an epic fail for you personally.
(Kelly laughs)
- I know, Pixar, it was Pixar.
- I know, I didn't hear
the specifics either.
But I looked to you cause
I was like Encanto, right?
And you were like Coco
and I was like, sure.
- [Lord] So there you
go, Lin-Manuel and Kelly.
You are the winners, you've done it.
(everybody cheers)
You've done it.
I didn't think you could,
to be honest with you.
I didn't think you could, but you did it.
- Yes. I love it.
Thank you, Lin.
Thank you to my winning
partner, Lin-Manuel Miranda.
(crowd cheers)
Angie Martinez and Ozuna for playing.
- Never coming back here.
- I know I will win, Angie, I know.